اهلا وسهلا اخونا احمد
مرحبا
اهلا بيك واهلا
بجمهور الجزيره على منصه الانستغرام
في نسخته الثانيه والعشرين في قطر لتكون
المره الاولى في الشرق الاوسط والمره
الاولى كذلك في دوله عربيه ومسلم والمره
الثانيه في قاره اسيا بعد مونديال كوريا
الجنوبيه واليابان عام 2016
كره القدم كل اربع سنوات وعلى مدار 21
نسخه صادقه تطورت اشكال حفلات الافتتاح
والتي تظهر فيها الدوله المنظمه ليس فقط
قدرتها وامكانياتها لتنظيم هذا الحدث
الكبير ولكن الاهم وعرض استثنائي ونادر
لاي دوله مستضيفه للترويجي لقيامها
والهويتها الثقافيه والارثها الحضاري عبر
هذا الحدث
افتتاح قطر 2022 باهتمام كبير محليا
وعربيا وعالميا اليوم ضيفنا هو احمد
الباكر الرئيس التنفيذي لاستوديوهات كتارا
ومخرجوا حفل افتتاح كاس العالم في قطر
2022 و سوف نحاول خلال هذه الحلقه ان
نقترب اكثر واكثر من كواليس افتتاح
المونديال وتفاصيل هذا الافتاء الاحتفال
المبهر
والذي شاهدناه بالامس وتباعه الملايين بل
المليارات اا حول العالم لنقترب معه اكثر
واكثر ايضا من حفل الختام الذي سيكون في
الثامن عشر من ديسمبر المقبل علنا نستطيع
خلال هذا البث الحي ان الله اكثر عما يمكن
ان نشاهده في حفل الافتتاح قبل ان نبدا مع
ضيفنا الكريم ونوه الى انه بامكاني مشاهدي
الجزيره عبر هذا اللايف ان يرسلوا
تعليقاتهم واسئلتهم همم لضيفنا والتي
سنقولها له تباعا يجيب عنها خلال هذه حلقه
احمد
اهلا وسهلا بك بعد
تاجيلات متكرره ومتكرره ومتكرره
اقول حق الشباب
نطول ساعات عمل يعني للفجر تعرف مع
ترتيبات الاستاذ في امور ثانيه
ان شاء الله يعني نقدر نكون معكم نجاوبكم
علي همم
اسالك تحديدا عن ردود الفعل
كان الجميع كان يعلم ان حجم الانتقادات
لكاس العالم في قطر كان وصل دورته بشكل
كبير قبل حفل الافتتاح
الان حفل الافتتاح راو الكثيرون انه مبهر
وانه نجح في ايصال رساله واضحه للعالم اا
ربما تكون في مضمون هذه الرساله هو رد على
الكثير من الانتقادات التي تعرضت لها قطر
في الفتره الاخيره كيف كانت ردود هذه يعني
ردود الفعل بشكل عام التي وصلتك عربيه
ومحليا وكذلك عالميا شوف يعني ممكن اجاوبك
على شقين من السؤال تقريبا
لفريق العمل احنا احنا فريق عمل متكامل
يعني من كوادر اكثريه وعربيه وايضا عالميه
شاركه في هذا الحفل لكن ال- ال- يعني
الاساس في هذا العمل كانت كوادر قطريه همم
[موسيقى]
وعربيه
كلنا الصراحه اليوم مو مستوعبين اول شيء
انه حفل افتتاح كاس العالم صار وان كاس
العالم في قطر يعني اليوم انا مو مستوعبنا
هذا واقع اييه امم استوعب ايضا ردود
الافعال الصراحه يعني
مثل ما يقولون
عوده اي شيء احنا نقدمه قابل ان في ناس
يحبونا او ينتقدونا يعني زي اي عمل فنيه
وحتى الفريق اللي معي
ونحس بمسؤوليه كبيره طبعا من الفخر همم
يعني ايجابيه ولا صدمه
يعني ما توقعنا ان الحدود بهذه الطريقه
يعني هذا دعم عمرنا ما توقعنا نشوفها شفنا
خلال ساعات فقط فيعني بالنسبه لنا هي شيء
مفرح
وفخر ومسؤوليه كبيره جدا همم
كشباب اا نقدم عمل اولا بهذا الحجم ونشكر
الجهات يعني المعنيه والمسؤولين انهم وثقه
في الكوادر القطريه
وشباب العرب ان احنا نمثلهم في هذا
البطوله همم واحنا نفتح البطوله هذه اللي
كانت حلم ل همم
للمسؤولين وحلم للقطريين وايضا حلم للعراق
يعني هي كانت المسؤول المسؤوليه كبيره جدا
من جميع النواحي
الشوط الثاني بس اللي اجاوبك عليه من
الانتقادات اتوقع اليوم يعني
المسؤوليه ايضا اللي كانت علينا احنا هذا
افتتاح كاس العالم فهو الافتتاح مش مساحه
لتصفيه حسابات همم
مثل ما تقول بقول لها بالعاميه ما بدي شخص
منها
لكن ايضا حسنا بالمسؤوليه ان اليوم اللي
انتقد قطار خلينا نكون واقعين ترى اللي
ينتقد ينتقد كل دوله عربيه وكل دوله مسلمه
همم لو مهما كان في هناك ممكن اختلاف في
وجهات النظر او غيره اللي ينتقدنا اليوم
قاعدين ينتقد الكلب فحسن بان لازم على
الاقل نحنا المراه لهذا الموضوع بشكل بسيط
جدا
وبدون ما يعني
ناخذ مساحتنا وبدون ما مثل ما قلت ان شخص
الموضوع في الحفل نجيبها باسلوب بسيطه
في المشهد التمثيل اللي صار بين همم اخوي
غانم المفتاح الفنان
ان ااه الاختلافات موجوده
اختلافات موجوده احنا مختلفين لكننا ايضا
نحن متشابهين
واختلافنا همم حلو همم
لاننا نتعرف على بعض بنشوف ان احنا جميلين
بسبت انه احنا مختلفين يعني الخلافات ترى
الاختلافات هنسميها مش الاختلافات هي
الحمار اللي بيخلي لنا انا وانت نتعرف على
بعض همم ونتعلم
فحبينا نوضحها لنا مستحيل يكون في طريقه
واحده طريقه الصحيحه فللغرب شايف ان
اسلوبه هو الاسلوب الصحيح في الحياه اذا
لابد من تصحيح المفاهيم ان احترام اختلاف
وجهات النظر واحترام اختلاف الثقافات لا
بدمن فاحنا مثل ما احنا نحترمك ضروري جدا
ان انت تحترمنا ولانك انت اليوم صحيت
وحسيت انك انت صحيت على شيء انت اعتبرته
الواقع وهو الطريق الصحيح مش معناته لازم
تجبر كل العالم انه يكون ماشي معك على على
نفس الاسلوب
عن موضوع التعايش واللي هو اساسي لتعارف
همم ما حبينا ان احنا فقط نقولها باسلوب
كل شيء
حبينا نكون جاي من منطقه صادق عندنا فكانت
الرمزيه بكل بساطه نحنا نعبر ونستدل من
الايه القرانيه اللي احنا رضينا عليها وهي
موجوده
التعايش موجود عندنا
الثقافات المختلفه ايضا موجود عندنا واحنا
راضيين عليه موجود في ثقافتنا لا هو بشيء
جديد اكتشفناه ولا هو بشيء دخيل علينا
بالعكس احنا عايشين حياتنا طول عمرنا بهذا
الاسم
بالعكس استطرد براحتك لكن انا بس انا هرجع
للتفاصيل بتاعه الحفله نفسها عشان خاطر
الحفله فيها تفاصيل كثير حابين ان احنا
نناقشها معاك كمان لكن انا حابب اتكلم
تحديدا عن ردود الفعل الدلتا استقبلتها هل
همم يعني وخاصه من خارج قطر او حتى من
خارج العالم العربي هل كانت في معظمها
ايجابيه هل كان في سلبيات معينه تم
الاشاره لها همم في الحفل وانتم همم
بتفكروا ربما في حفل الختام تحاولوا
تتفادوها بشكل او باخر انا عايز اعرف منك
ردود الفعل تحديدا ثم ثم هننتقل بالتفصيل
للحفله لكل الفقرات اللي فيها
شوف شوف احنا قدمنا مجموعه اعمال لكاس
العالم مجموعه الاعمال اللي قدمناها اااه
كاي عمل فني جاك عليه انتقادات في ناس حبه
والبعض الامور في ناس شافوا الزاويه اللي
احنا كنا ماخذينها في بعض الاعمال هذه لان
قدمنا اعمال متنوعه اللي منها رسميا وبعض
الاعمال الثانيه اللي قدمناه لكاس العالم
همم يعني اختلاف وجهه نظر في الاعمال هذه
يعني زيها مثل اي اي عمل فني موجود
لحد الان اييه خلال ال 24 ساعه اللي فاتوا
لحفل الافتتاح انا شخصيا ما وصلتني
انتقادات يمكن موجوده او يمكن لازم ابحث
عنها وتعرف 24 ساعه
والمشاعر متلخبطه ما بين الواحد بيريح
وواحد يبكي يعني دموع كل اللي بعده ما
وصلني شيء
لا من الجمهور القطري ولا من الجمهور
العربي ولم الجمهور العالمي يمكن في اشياء
همم موجوده واكيد الفريق الفريق العمل
عندنا راح يشوفها لان احنا جدا
همم ابراهيم جمهور ودائما همم
بشكل جدا واضح تعلمنا منه يعني مثلا لما
عملنا افتتح كاس العرب اخذنا بعين
الاعتبار الامور اللي تجاوب معاها الجمهور
الامور اللي شوي انتقدها الجمهور اللي سوت
بعض يعني دائما ندرس كل شيء سويناه كذلك
كاس العرب
بعض اللوحات التصويريه كان يعني كاس
العالم حفله افتتاح كاس العالم
في بعض الناس تحس ان في تكرار في فكره همم
اغاني كل الدول هي كانت نفس الامور في
حفله افتتاح كاس العرب كان برده اغاني كل
الدول الناشيد الوطنيه
هل احد وصل لك المعلومه دي او كانت في
الاعتبار ههه
فعليا لكن التكرار مقصود
خصوصا انه نقدر نسمي لنا التكرار هو يعني
نابع من ستايل همم
ستايلي واستايل الفريق اللي معي يعني انت
عاده العمل لمخرج وفريق الانتاج دائما لما
تشوف مال لهم ما راح اقول ان في تكرار فيه
رتابه لكن في تكرار مانشستر
انا شخصيا المحب ل همم فريق
نشوف ان طريقه التواصل مع الجمهور لما ااا
لما التواصل معاهم عبر
نستولجيا دائما في شعور يصير شخصي بينك
وبين الجمهور فانا دائما محب لاي شيء وانا
كذلك ايضا كمشاهد شيء يداعب حسن مستولجه
عندي استمتع فيه لاعب عشتها استمتع فيها
السياره احب العمل اكثر
بالنسبه لنا كفريق هذه هو الشيء اللي احنا
حبينا ناخذه فلما مثلا همم
لما نشوف اغاني كاس العالم
اول شيء القصه من وراها هي ان احنا بغينا
نحتفل بالبطولات السابقه كلها لان همنا من
الموضوع شعار
كل البطولات همم افتتاح كاس العالم طب
خلينا ناخدهم بالترتيب هم كانوا في سبعه
لوحات
تصويريهم اغنيه لدانه همم
اغنيه الاخرى اللي همم الفنان الكوري
الجنوبي جون
والفنان القطري فهد الكبيسي
وكذلك المشهد التنفيذي اللي كان موجود في
همم همم غانم
وكان موجود في الممثل الامريكي مرجان
بريمن
اشرح لنا بالتفصيل خلينا ناخذ لوحه لوحه
من اللوحات التصويريه اللي حصلت واشرح لنا
خلفيتها والرساله اللي انت كنت حابب
توصلوها من خلال هذه اللوحه الفنيه
انتقالا للي بعدها ثم اللي بعدها ثم اللي
بعدها
وكل شيء يبلش بالفيديو اللي بلش في بدايه
الحفل
الفيديو هذا يبلش فيه نداء وهو عباره عن
همم رحله همم يسردها لنا همم مورجان
فالهدف من الفيديو كان هو توضيح الموقع
الجغرافي الحفل وللقصه اللي احنا راح نشوف
فيها حفل الافتتاح كاس العالم الموقع
الجغرافي اللي هو قطر مدينه الخور طابعها
الصحراوي والبري
فطلعنا من البحر متابعين همم
الحوت همم القرش اللي هو احنا بنسميهم
عندنا في القطاع
هذا يعني همم من البيئه القطريه همم
جدا مهم في البيئه القطريه وايضا لا همم
رمزيات خاصه بالنسبه لنا في الحفل اا سهل
انك انت تاخذ عليها انطباع من اول مره
تشوفها انه يكون كائن مخيفه تخش منها همم
او حاجه اسطوريه يعني او حاجه بالضبط
لان سهل جدا انك انت تخاف من اللي تجهلها
او تنتقد الليله همم فحسينا في انها
الكائن يعني متشابه شويه فينا العالم يمكن
ما يعرفنا وسهل انه ما بيبحث انه يدافع
عنه لما تطلع مقاله عن حد يقول عنه شيء
معين
فحسينا ان ال- ال- هذا جدا يعني خصوصا انه
من البيئه البحريه القطريه جدا همم يعني
مرتبط
فالفيديو هذا يبلش لتحديد الموقع الجغرافي
فنسمع في النداء النداء هذا احنا نبي نقول
للعالم انه قطر تنادي
الاستجابه ولما صار النداء
يستجيبون من مختلف دول العالم فالفيديو
يروي لنا رمزيات معينه
لشعوب
من
قارات مختلفه امريكا استراليا اوروبا
اسيا نشوفهم الى قطر مختلفه هذول كلهم في
رحله عبر ال ال من البحر تبلش الى البر
مثل ما شفنا في الفيديو رايحين الاتجاه
واحد اللي هو نسمع منه صوت الندى صوت
النداء هذه
جاي من الهوى الهاون عندنا لان ندق
وينطحن فيه القهوه لان ندق هاي فيه نوع من
النداء من القهوه
هي عباره عن النداء اللي استقبلت الشعوب
الهاجري قطر همم وتجيب بالاخص في استاد
البيت اللي هو خيمه همم
الخيمه العربيه بيت الشعر اللي موجوده
ايضا في همم منطقه الخور في الصحراء فطبعا
دخلنا المشاهد لقطات الحفل لو لاحظت كان
لقطات همم
جرافيك في الاستاد البيت في الصحراء كلمه
قطعنا درويش بدلنا نشوف الطريقه
التقليدي اللي موجود في ال- همم في همم في
اي افتتاح اخر رحنا للشخص السينماتك شويه
همم يدخلنا في مود القفل هذا
النداء هذا دخلنا في اللوحه الاولى في
ارضيه الملعب في اللايف اللي هو همم
بعنوان اللي هو النداء لما سمعنا فيها
كلمات همم غنائيه للفنانه القطريه دانا
واللي هذا اول ظهور لها ايضا واول من سبع
صوتها انا عندي سؤال بس هي انا اللي كانت
بتغني في الاستاد اوكي
حتى النداء لما اخذناه اخذناه من اغنيه
موجوده في تراثنا القطري والخليجي بالاخص
خصوصا في الكويت والبحرين و قطار عندنا
هذه
الاغنيه التراثيه اسمها توبي يا بحر احنا
طبعا كلمات توب يا بحر موجوده عندنا في
قطر بين توب يا بحر وبين ايضا اغنيه
تراثيه اسمها ام الحنايا فيها تكرار نفس
الكلمات وهي موجوده ايضا بحر نفس الكلمات
ايضا موجوده همم في الكويت
همم الحريم همم الاول على البحر همم
لطال الصفر ل- همم عند الغاصه وطالعه
لطاله المده وما رجعوا فكان كان النداء
للبحر انه همم
يعني يرد لنا يرجعهم ثاني
فكان نداء ايضا فاحنا قلنا لما بنخلي
الشخصيه اللي عندنا في الحفل تنادي
خليها تنادي من شيء موجود من تراثنا لا
نكتب اغنيه جديده بعد هذا شيء يداعب حسن
انه الاغنيه هذه احنا رضينا عليها يعني في
قطره في الخليل يعني اي حد يغني الاغنيه
هذه في الخليج بيعرف يرددها بس طبعا احنا
قدمناها باسلوب مختلف همم لما تسمعها اول
مره ما تلقط هذه الاغنيه ليه ما سمعت يمكن
مره ثانيه او
لنسخ تقريبا
سلامات اسلوب موسيقى تصويريه
فهذا النداء جمع الشعوب ولا يتجمعوا كلهم
قال لابد من
ان يكون في شخص غريب على هذا النداء انه
يطلع لشخصيه اخرى لمثل الجيل الحالي ويمثل
الناس اللي اللي قلبه النداء
فيه نوع من
في نوع من الشيء اللي هو يبحث عنه
حب يعني بشكل ما
بعرف
انتم انتم ليش انا موجوده
فهي بلش الحوار بين شخص يمثل همم
وجهات نظر مختلفه
وعند الرغبه ان انه يعرف كيف ممكن يتواصل
وبين شخصيه عندنا تمثل الجيل الشباب
[موسيقى]
همم متفقين متعايشين في الاخير فكان لابد
من
التحيه فالتحيه قلنا بدال ايضا بدار
اغنيه جديده نقدمها لان يعني اتنشنز
الجمهور يستوعب اغنيه جديده في حفل لاول
مره همم ما راح يكون سريع احنا تبغي شيء
يحرك مشاعره
فرحنا لاغنيه موجوده وخصوصا عند الخليجيين
اذا غليتها عند الخليجيين بيعرفونها وايضا
مرتبطه بالرياضه وفيها نوع من الترحيب
اللي هي اغنيه هلا همم
من تلحين الفنان القطري المرحوم عبد
العزيز ناصر همم قدمها لخليج 11
وشارك فيها ايضا مجموعه من الفنانين
الخليجيين ومنذ الخليج 11 الى اليوم في اي
حفل رياضي يتغنى فيها اهل الخليل
بنقدمها لابد بدنا الكل راح يعرف شلون
يتجاوب معها هي ايضا يعني مثل ما تقول
يعني انا يعني احنا كفريق هنا حبينا ان كل
فقره تكون موجوده عندنا نقدر نعطيه مثل
نجد
لجمهور معين جمهور نبي نتواصل معه الجمهور
الخليه ترى انت موجود في الحفل ويانا احنا
نسوي شيء واحنا نسوي شيء بس حق الجمهور
العالم
رحله لمجموعه اشياء نقدر نربط كل الامور
فيها فكانت الخاتمه هناك هتسلم من الولكم
تسلمنا للفقره اللي بعدها اللي ابتدينا
نروح فيها انتقال لاهازيج ال ال الجماهير
ومن ثم اغاني كاس العالم الى اخر
همم
انت حاسس ان الرساله اللي كنتم عايزين
توصلوها وصلت
والله الصراحه احس ان يعني
ما اخاف اجابتي تقول يعني تبين لنا فيها
اوفر كونفدنس لكن التوضيح فقط احنا كنا
خايفين ان ما بتوصل رساله
الافكار بصراحه كنا متوفي يعني لدرجه انه
نفكر كيف ممكن ما بعد الحفل همم نعمل مواد
نعمل مجموعه همم ممكن تفهم الناس الحفل
لان يمكن يمكن احنا يعني وايد افكار في
الحفل في مده الزمنيه قصيره الجمهور ما
بيلحق انه ينتبه عليها الاخير
همم
مش انتم بس اللي كان عندكم ناس قائمين على
الحفل لكن حتى الجمهور العربي بشكل محدد
كان عنده تخوف نظرا لان هو كان عنده نقد
بشكل متكرر له بعض اغاني كاس العالم
بعيده شويه عن توقعاته في ان همم الاغاني
عن العالم العربي وتعبر عن قطر كدوله
عربيه وعن عادات وتقاليد هذه الشعوب
العربيه بشكل كبير ااه خاصه الاغنيه
الاخيره ال- ال- اللي غنت فيها
الفيتامينات ومعلومه ومريام فارس اتعرضت
لنقد همم
اللغه العربيه
همم كلهم مرتبطين في بعض وهي فكره جديده
بحدتها ولنا اجابه واضحه جدا عليها يعني
ونتمنى يمكن مثلا همم الجمهوريه يسمعها
اتمنى له تعطيني فرصه اتكلم عنها همم بس
مهم جدا وضح ان الاغاني الرسميه اللي
نزلوا كلهم الاغنيه اللي همم التكتوك هي
لا تعتبر نيه همم
فيفا قطر رسميه لفيفه قطر هي اغنيه رسميه
للفيفا للفن فيست وطبعا اغنيه يعني لها
جمهورها اييه
عليها بعض الانتقادات صحيح لكنها جمهورها
ايضا الاغنيه مالها علاقه احنا ما
انتجناها همم
[موسيقى]
يعني انتاجها جميل وفيها يعني هي عمل فنيه
قابله الانتقاد وقابل ايضا همم للنجاح في
ناس يحبونها جدا وفي ناس بتقدر جوانب فيها
همم يعني شافوها غير صحيح لكن هذه ما لها
علاقه في العلاقات اللي احنا قدمناها
وايضا ما لها علاقه الدوله المستضيفه اللي
هي قطر لها علاقه في الفيفا وهي اغنيه
تروج للفيفا اللي هو مهرجان فيه مربوطه
بهذا الشكل لكن لو اجاوبك على اغنيه ال-
همم الاغاني الرسميه
الفيفا كان فيها
مغامره
اول مره نحنا من قطر
قدمنا فكره جديده قلنا يا جماعه خلونا
نقدم
البوم احنا اليوم وصلنا
يعني اليوم الاغاني تنزل بكثره
اللي موجودين انت تسمع اغاني اول باول
اتنشنز سريع موجود
في جمهور العربيه
[موسيقى]
ايضا خصوصا امريكا اللاتينيه مهم وفي
اللهجه الانجليزيه اللي صايره سهله في
عالم الانترنت اليوم انك توصل للجميع لكن
خليني اقول لك ليش اللي سويناه اليوم مميز
همم هو مشكله ردت لنا احلى تردد للفيفا
ايضا الانتقاد
يعني الخطوه الجريئه اليوم لانه صار عندنا
امكانيه ان قدم مجموعه من الاغاني صرنا
نقدر فعلا ان احنا نعبر عن جو كاس العالم
كاس العالم ما يصير يكون اغنيتها فقط
بالانجليزي وتوكل تقول ترى اغنيكم معظمها
بالانجليزي
عن عن الدوله نفسها عن قطر نفسها عن
هويتها عن ثقافتها اعتبر ان افتتاح كاس
العالم
لكاس
العالميه كانت الفكره ان احنا اليوم عندنا
فرصه نقدم تنوع ثقافي
ونعمل الامور لاول مره تصير في كاس العالم
خليني اقول لك اوكي
كاس العالم فرنسا همم 98
شنو الاغنيه الرسميه طبعا الاغنيه ناجحه
جدا اكيد
صغننه اغنيه يعني ما زالت حد هذه اللحظه
محفوره في الاذان
مره ثانيه
يعني فرنسا
بالفرنساوي تقريبا
بالانجليزي لكاس العالم
ما عمل نسخه فرنسيه عمل
لكن الاغنيه الرسميه تاج ضعيفه
نفسها اصلا هي كانت اغنيه موجوده
صحيح
بشكل كبير جدا الاغنيه الرسميه تبعهم
بالانجليزي
الاغنيه هذه ايضا نفس الشيء ما اخذت
الطابع
الاسيوي في الموضوع
اول فنان فرنسي
يغني بالفرنسي في كاس العالم
اللي كشفنا عن الافتتاح هذه اول اغنيه اول
يوم احنا كنا عارفين ان هذه الاغنيه هي
بتكون في حفله لان الاغنيه عاطفيه لكن
اغنيه البطوله كلنا كنا حاسين راح تكون
ارحم
السبب رحنا لاحد الرعاه الرسميين والتنسيق
مع الفيفا بدنا نعمل نسخه عربيه ولا الناس
راح تكون النسختين هذول موجودين ونبي
بنحتفل فيهم لان الجو الكروي فيهم عالم
والاغنيه الحمد لله صار لها اصدقاء خصوصا
قبل البطوله بشوي زادت اصلاح بشكل كبير
الاغاني الثانيه
لما قدم تكون حاطه افكار والافكار هذه
تكون حاط لك انت طموح انها توصل لمكان
معين في جمهوري يتقبلها في جمهور ما
يتقبلها يعني اكيد احنا شفنا الانتقادات
على الاغنيه هذه
اكثر اغنيه فعلا تعرضت لنقط مباشر
يعني الانتقادات واضحه يمكن في الفنانين
نفسهم اللي في الاغنيه ايضا شافوها
ومنتبهين عليها واحنا منتبهين عليها همم
وايضا احنا نشوف الجانب الثاني منها همم
ايضا عمل الفن
ممكن تقول لي حاجه من ضمن الحاجات اللي
كانت واضحه بالنسبه لك انت مخرج همم
بنظره فنيه انت حسيت انها في نقد جاء لهذه
الاغنيه وانت حسيت ان هو كان في محله
الوحيده اللي انا ممكن اتفق فيها يعني من
الانتقادات الكثيره كلها
ليش ما حطينا ليش ما حطينا عربي فقط
[موسيقى]
هذا اليوم احنا ممكن نعطيهم اييي طبعا هم
فنانات وكبار كلهم اساميهم في الوسط الفني
همم لكن لهم جمهور جديد في الاغنيه هذه
بيروحون لجمهور
لاتيني بيروحوا لجمهور امريكي اوروبي غلط
ان انت تعطينا احنا كل يوم يعني نسمع
اغانيهم الجميله بالعربي بس ليش ما نعطيهم
الفرصه انهم يغنون بالانجليزي وخصوصا انه
متمكنين يعني مش انهم مش متمكنين فيعني
كاي عمل فني همم قابل للانتقاد متخلقه
باللغه العربيه باللغه الاسبانيه ربما
واللغه الفرنسيه بحيث ان انت وباللغه
الانجليزيه ايضا بحيث انك انت توصل لاكبر
قدر ممكن من الجمهور كما في العالم بما ان
البطوله هي بطوله عالميه يعني بالضبط كلنا
نبي نعكس شعور شوف الرياضه والفن يجمعون
الناس
فاليوم احنا بغينا نيجي بالرياض والفن مع
بعض في مكان واحد من خلال الالبوم هذا كنا
لما لما جبنا فكره الالبوم طبعا بالتعاون
مع الفيفا والالبوم
الفكره خطيره للاول مره قصيره في كاس
العالم لكنها فكره معتمده بقى فيفا ساوند
وراح تتم في البطولات الجايه لكن احنا لان
نسوي الالبوم لاول مره كان من صعب ترى
يحلوا ما كان في البوم
يعني اغلب الظن ان كنا راح نختار بين
ارحبوا ودريمرز انها تكون الاغنيه الرسميه
اولنا نروح نثبت موضوع ان اي اغنيه راح
نختارها كانت ممكن تكون فيها انجليزي
وعربي ان المقطع العربي ياخذ حقه بالشكل
الصحيح لان هذا شيء
كقطريين كخليجيين عمرنا ما نتخلى عنك وانت
شوف هذا الشيء موجود عندنا في قطر وفي
الخليج وحتى في العالم العربي للشيخ جاء
عندنا مستحيل ان احنا نطلع منها وما نحط
بصماتنا صوت
السؤال فيما يتعلق بالاغاني طبعا في اغاني
زي ما احنا كنا ذكرنا في اثناء الاستعراض
بتاعتنا الاغاني كاس العالم اللي فاتت
يعني في انت قلت همم الاغنيه بتاعه
وفي حديث ايضا عن اغنيه شاكيرا في 2010
واكا واكا والاغنيه بتاعه لكوبا دولابيه
لبيدا اللي هي اللي غناها في كاس العالم
والاثنين دول تحديدا عن كؤوس العالم وعن
كل اغاني كؤوس العالم اللي بتغنيت قبلها
وبعدها الاغنيتين دول حتى هذه اللحظه
حاضرين ومسمعين والناس بيحبوا يسمعوها
بشكل متكرر ربما اا في حفلات او في
مسابقات او او
هل
شايف ان ان ربما لسه في فرصه ان يكون في
اغنيه لكاس العالم قطر 2022
يسمعها الناس بشكل متكرر وتسيب اثر وعلامه
مستمره لعقود طويله قبل ما ينتهي كاس
العالم
كل اللي حضر بطوله كاس العالم قطر راح
ياخذ معه اردنيه لكن بعد عشر سنوات ان شاء
الله انا اقول لك اني ارحبوا هي الاغنيه
اللي بتكون فيها ذكريات كاس العالم كما هو
الحال مع كوكا كما هو الحال مع لايف في
نقطه مهمه ان الاغاني الرسميه الحكم عليها
ما بعد البطوله بالسنوات او ما بعد
البطوله مش في البطوله نفسها
واكا واكا عشنا فيها اثناء البطوله يعني
الحين انت الحين اثناء البطوله اذا ما عشت
ارحبوا وما تحمست معاها هالايام وانت في
البطوله اذا اعرف انها ما حد بيذكرها في
السنوات القادمه لكن انا اوردي شايف
الجمهور كيف قعد يتعامل معها الجمهور
العرب يغني فيها
وخصوصا كل ما قربنا للبطوله ومن بلشت
البطوله في الملعب امس في الافتتاح شغاله
في البهاقراهم عند الناس حلو
فالاغاني هذه مربوطه بالفايت شعور البطوله
شعور البطوله كيف راح يكون نرجع على عنصر
الاستولجه راح تتذكرها طبعا احنا بالنسبه
لنا يمكن احنا يعني
اول كاس
امريكا يعني كنا لسه 12 كده يعني ايه ههه
اتذكر اشياء منها يعني في 94 اتذكر ان كان
منتخب السعوديه
منتخب السعوديه مبدع فيعني منتخب عربي
وكلنا كنا مش لاقيه ونقعد قدام
ففيه لهذكريات معينه بس بعدين لما تروح
على 97 همم
98 سوري همم
تصير ذكريات اكثر واكثر عندك فاهمني انت
بالنسبه لك الاغنيه هذه بتذكر كل شيء فيها
تتذكر تتذكر ضابط كاس العالم بشكل عام نفس
الشيء همم
ولو تلاحظ سواء كافر
معناها مش اغنيه رسميه صحيح راسي
يعتبرونها رسميه يعني هو البطوله بحد
ذاتها والاكشن اللي يصير فيها يعني ترى لو
ناقص صوت افريقيا بنفسها كبطوله كان فيها
مجموعه من الاكشن ومن الاحداث همم اللي
صارت في البطوله اللي يخلي البطوله نفسها
يعني
كل الامور هذه خليك تتذكر الاغنيه مالتهم
مميزه بس هل ده معناه ان احنا مش هنسمع
اغنيه مختلفه همم الختام في الختام همم
في الختام خلاص ما عادش فيها اغاني
خلاص
هذه اللي نزلناها في الكشفنا عنها خنسميها
في حفله الافتتاح اخر اغنيه وهي فيها
صراحه لي شخصيا جدا قريبه للفريق لان فيها
الامساك قطريه من همم
من همم يعني تراث القطري من فن اسمه الفن
المخفي اللي هو من تراب اهل البحر همم
وفيها لحام من تراث اهل البحر ايضا همم
ونسمع فيها فهد الكبيسي في مقطع غنائي
جميل جدا
الاغنيه هذه همم
نسميها نشيد همم لكاس العالم همم اكتشفنا
عنها امس في حفل الافتتاح نزل الاوديو
تبعها اليوم وقاعد يحقق نجاح جميل ما شاء
الله يعني تبارك الله عصاره الحين همم رقم
واحد
90 دوله اا في الايتونز همم نزل
البرودكاست تبعها وهمم والميزك همم فيديو
همم تبعها بينزل ان شاء الله غدا همم
فبالنسبه ان هذه تكون اخر همم اغاني قطر
اغاني كاس العالم
طيب همم همم
هارجع وراء شويه همم التجهيز بتاع الحفل
الافتتاح تحديدا خد منكم وقت قد ايه
تقريبا وامتى تحديدا بداتم في التفكير لكل
الفقرات ديت اللي انتم عملتوها
وكلمني عن شعورك لما تم تكلفك انت ان انت
تشيل المهمه الثقيله دي
الصراحه
انا ترى معي فريق عمل كبير جدا همم يعني
من الشباب القطريين والعراق مثل ما قلت لك
اللي بدونهم يعني ما اقدر
فاحنا كلنا نكمل بعض الناس
يعني قائد الفريق يمكن
مش اذا مثلا شفت شيء عبقري في العمل مو
بشرط يكون طالع مني عرفت يمكن يكون من حد
من الشباب من ربعنا يعني كل منه قال فكره
وعجبتنا وحولنا نحطها وفي افكار جديده
كبيره يعني لو كان معطينا مساحه بعد يعني
ما عندنا مشكله احنا احنا كلنا في
الفيديوهات كثار ترى مخرجين همم السينما
وهمم
يعني هاي اللي احنا بنسويه اكثر يعني احنا
يعني نحب الاعمار الروائيه نحب السير الحب
لما جئنا احنا نعمل شيء لايف على شيء
على فكره لذلك
تجربتنا في كاس العرب
ايضا احنا عملناه همم في حفظ القرعه كاس
العالم شهر اربعه لعنه كان يعني همم
بالمقارنه بح- كاس العرب وكاس العالم همم
لكن درسنا التجارب هذه وحبينا ان احنا
اكثر واكثر كيف ممكن نوصل للجمهور بشكل
كاس العالم فكرتها احنا بلشنا نخطط لها
يعني
اليوم الثاني يعني بعد كاس العرب على طول
كافكار
تفريخ عمل متكامل
ونقعد مع الجهات المعنيه ومع الاجنظمه
نفهم اللجنه المنظمه ايش اللي الافكار
والمسجد
والثيمه اللي راح تكون فيها همم
قطر اثناء البطوله كلها مجموعه بريوس
التحضيرات الاساسيه فعلا صارت همم نهايه
الشهر فقط
لكن الفكره
وفكره الفقرات وطبعا قلبنا الامور غيرنا
والحبكات والامور هذه كلها اخذت شهور
موجوده من
يعني شهر 12 الماضي
وطبعا ماشيه خلينا نقول بالتوازي مع
فكره اغاني همم كاس العالم
وبالتوازي ايضا مع
التعويل الرسميه
لها فنان رسمتها
احنا اخذناها بنيناها الدرامي همم لعيب
انه جاي من عالم التعويذات
وطورناه شخصيه 3d ولكن احنا ماسكين كل شيء
لا يعني اليوم لما تجي الدوحه يشوف له
عروض معينه شوفه على هولوجرامز همم
الحلقات المتواجده في اليوتيوب
الخاص انها يدخل في مباريات في تاريخ كره
القدم وامور مثل هذه كلها عندنا فريق
متخصص عندنا في الاستديو ماسك همم لعيب
والفيديو الاساسي اللي كشفنا عنا في لما
كشفنا عن التعويذه الرسميه في همم اثناء
القرعه ايضا
همم
طيب انا عايز اقول لك
[موسيقى]
طبعا مرتبط لما كشفنا عنه انه جاي من عالم
التعويضات ورجعنا للناس وذكرناهم
بالتعويضات السابقه هذا لاحبك ايضا في حفل
الافتتاح لما شفناهم مره ثانيه طيب الواحد
تعود نوعا ما في العالم العربي على ان لما
يكون في حدث مهم جدا وهمم
وبيحتل اولويه واهميه للدوله العربيه ايا
كانت هذه الدوله العربيه غالبا غالبا
بيستعينه بشخص اجنبي
اللي يدير هذا الامر او يرسم هذه الخريطه
او يحط اللمسه بتاعته في في في في العرض
اللي هيتقدم للعالم كله دوت الحقيقه انا
همم انا سمعت ان في مخرج قطري
هو اللي هيخرج
الحفل الافتتاح وده خلاني اتساءل ده دي
مغامره كبيره دي ولا ايه ولا هو عامل
حاجات قبل كده
انا حابه تكلمني عن شعورك هل هل دي ثقه
ثقه بشكل كبير انت شايف ان
المسؤولين منحوها همم لك
شاب قطري للقيام بهذه المهمه همم اللي هي
يعني تم قعده قعده البلد تحضر لها اكثر من
12 سنه تقريبا
في قطر ما تنقص للامكانيات ان احنا نجيب
افضل واحد في العالم
ينتج لنا حفل الافتتاح لكن اتوقع الرؤيه
اللي موجوده عند المنظمه
والمسؤولين والقياده عندنا
عندهم رؤيه بعد
ولله الحمد انه اعطونا الفرصه هذه
واعطونا فرصه انه مش غلط ان انت بتسوي غلط
على الاقل
فرصه يعني لو اليوم لو طولت معك ساعات
وعبر عن هذه الفرصه ما راح اقدر
اوقفوا الثقه فيني وفي فريق العمل اللي
معي همم الشباب والشابات القطريين وايضا
العرب اللي معنا في فريق العمل همم يعني
هذا الشيء احنا عمرنا ما رح انسايد في
التاريخ عندنا همم
احنا قدرنا ان احنا نكون فيه عمل بهذا
المستوى همم مغامره للمسؤولين نعم لكن
تحدي لنا تحدي ان احنا نثبت ان احنا قد
المسؤوليه ان شاء الله
الصراحه همم الجمهور
دائما لما لما سمعنا من امس راي الجمهور
في الموضوع
كله جدا مبسوطين
الجمهور خاص باحساس من المشاعر
الجميله اللي شافه
يعني الحمد لله توفيق من رب العالمين
وفعلا لما انت تقدر تقول
قصتك بنفسك افضل من احد ثاني يقولها
بلسانه
واتوقع هذا العنصر يمكن العنصر البصري همم
ممكن يكون اكبر واحلى يعني
بعشر مره
لكن ساعات الشيء اللي نابع من عندك من
داخل من هنا ترى يبغي على
همم العنسي ممكن يكون في روح اكثر وهو دوت
اللي بيصنع الفرق اللي انت كنت دائما
بتحاول تستجربه بكل اعمالك الخاصه بالنسبه
للمشاهد او الحاضر
ينفعل عاطفيا وده شيء صعب مش سهل اي شكل
من الاشكال
طيب ده هيخليني اروح اكتب بقى لاحمد
الباكر انا عايز اعرف الناس على احمد
الباكر اكثر عايزين نتعرف عليك
ازاي بدات رحلتك في في الاخراج انت قررت
انك انت تشتغل مخرج ايه اهم الاعمال اللي
قدمتها في في الفتره اللي فاتت وهنتحدث
برده اا يعني باختصار بعد ذلك عن كثار
المؤسسه اللي انت رئيس التركي
في الجزيره ههه
[موسيقى]
اي نعم
اخوي الله يسلمك انا يعني بلشت يعني انا
احب مجال ال ال يعني كونتينشن بشكل
افلام مسلسلات اي شيء في انترتينمنت اي
شيء فيه
يعني ماده مرئيه او مسموعه
شيء كان فاشل عندي منظر يعني ااا
بلشت يعني اخذت المجال هذا انه يكون هو
مجال الفني يعني ما درسته همم انا فعليا
يعني كنت تقني همم سوري همم
تقريبا مده ثلاث سنوات
وعقبها يعني قررت اغير المهنه
وكانت مغامره لان ما في
ما في صناعه للمحتوى فعليا في قطر وكانت
في الفتره 2010
ما كان في فرصه للانتاج تحاول اتعلم اعمل
افلام قصيره اشارك باي شيء ممكن يصير
وتوافقت ان فيه مجموعه
شباب مجانين نفسي يبون يعملون صناعه ويبون
همم يعني
يعني عندهم طاقه يطلعونها هذا الشيء ما
يكون
[موسيقى]
مايكون مثل ما تقول
فقط هوايه يكون هي المهنه تبعهم
ويعني من ذيك الفتره عملنا على اعمال
مختلفه منها لا لا الاعلانات منها افلام
قصيره
منها
همم يعني بعض البرامج اللي شرحنا في
انتاجها واخراجها وغيره
طبعا كان الموضوع سهل لك لله الحمد اليوم
انا وفريقي هذه مهنتنا يعني ما عندنا شغل
ثاني غير هذا الموضوع وتحت يعني
همم في الوقت الحالي الفريق عندنا شغلنا
فعلا اداري فيها لكن انا اداري ولكن ايضا
اشتغل يعني انا ممكن اكون مدير اليوم لكن
بكره انا مخرج في نفس الوقت وكذلك هو
الحال عندنا احد منتج ثاني بروجكت هو
المخرج همم
يعني الى اخرى عندنا مثل ما تقول يعني
شيء خاص صاير في في في الشركه وقدرنا
اليوم ان احنا نكون هذه محناتنا لا بد
انها في المستقبل راح تبني تفتح المجال
[موسيقى]
لصناع محتوى ممكن يصير عندهم ممكن يكون
لهم مصدرها لها ان ان فعلا همم صناعه
المحتوى قد يكون
انتهاوي فقط
المحتوى مهمه جدا
بتقوم على تاسيسها دلوقت اللي هي صناعه او
يعني قلب صناع محتوى ويدعمهم بشكل كبير
احنا شركه
يعني همم احنا قسمنا كثار لكن همم
احنا تابعين تحت مظله كثاره ومدعوين من
كثاره كمشغل
للاستوديوهات لكن الشركه اوبريتسون كومار
كومارش البيتسوس
على اسس ربحيه فاحنا مش مؤسسات تدعم
وتعملوا مثل هذا بالعكس
كلنا موجودين همم على طاقتنا اليوم قدرنا
نعمل كويس في ال- في ال- في المجال ونعم
الاعمال رح نكون بارتاح كشركه ما قدرنا
همم يعني تنزل ايراداتنا احنا تصير الامور
صعبه
وهذا جزء من التحدي خلينا نلبي يكون عندنا
الانتاجيه المستمر همم لكن ايضا لان احنا
علينا في البدايه على اساس نكون همم
اساس يعني يكون عندنا مستقبل في هذه
الصناعه دائما يكون عندنا المبادره انه
لما نشوف صانع محتوى ونقدر ندعمه بشيء
يعني ما يكلفنا ماديا ممكن يكلفنا جهديه
من الماده اللي تساعده ان احنا انه يخلص
العمل نشوف متى عندنا وقت فراغ نقدر نضبط
السالفه عندنا ولا دخل المشروع عندنا
واحنا بنشتغل عليه
هذا الشخص اللي بنعمله قد يكون شخص احنا
بكره ممكن يكون جزء من يعني في الاخر
اشتغل برنامج
يحبك جدا انا على فكره همم
يعني اتمنى من قناه الجزيره ههه
طيب انا انا عندي سؤالين اخرين هسالهم لك
والحديث معك الحقيقه ان هو ممتع هو ممكن
يمتد لساعات وساعات يعني همم لكن همم
السؤال الاولاني هل همم هنشوفك في حفل
الختام كمخرج لحفل الختام
همم يعني
ايه بس ههه نعم
ممكن نتعرف
النجم الاول والاخير هو
الفريقين اللي بيلعبوه
في الختام ترى الناس بتذكر بتذكرونه اقصد
ايش مين هو
فيعني لهذا السبب راح يكون حفل مبسط
[موسيقى]
يعني
مرتكز على شيء بسيط جدا لانه نبي تركيز
خلاص
متناسب مع الختام هذا ثاني همم
15 دقيقه
بسالك اه يعني
هيبقى في كم فقره تقريبا
[ضحك]
اغنيه جديده قصدك يعني اغنيه جديده لحفل
الختام
لا يعني الى الان اذا في شيء
ممكن يكون شيء بيطلع لكن
اقدم
هل هي اغنيه رسميه من اغاني سكر
موسيقى تخص الحق تمام في حد بسالك من
جمهور بيقول لك انت درست اخراج
تمام اخر سؤال هل في رساله حبيب توصلها
لاهل قطر الشباب في العالم العربي
للناس في العالم اللي بيتابعوا كاس العالم
حاله توصل رسائلك
والله الصراحه الشيء الوحيد اللي ممكن
اقوله انه كاس العالم موجود اليوم في قطر
موجود في العالم العربي
فخلينا نحتفل فيه لانه فعلا حلم وكنا
مصدقينه انه بيتحقق لكن اليوم فعلا صار
موجود يعني حتى يعني الشعور انه هو اليوم
موجود هنا في قطر
جميل
همم التبادل الثقافي اللي ممكن يصير فيه
اااه وخلي احتفل بالرياضه نفسها
تمام انا بشكرك شكرا جزيلا يا احمد على
هذا الحوار
يعني واحنا كلنا فخورين بما قدمته في حفله
الافتتاح نتمنى ان شاء الله نحن نشوف في
حفل الاجتماع
جزيلا وان شاء الله باذن الله على امل كده
يكون لنا لقاءات متكرره ربما او قبله ان
شاء الله باذن الله
شكرا جزيلا احمد
الله يخليك
على خير سلام عليكم وشكرا لكم كذلك
مشاهدينا الكرام